es probable que el presidente chino
parta mañana de Moscú con comunicados
conjuntos de amistad eterna y
colaboración estrecha china Rusia sin
embargo ven la Cumbre de forma diferente
para china es una oportunidad para la
paz y la estabilidad global china
pretende acabar urgentemente con una
guerra que entre otros prejuicios la
costado la sintonía con Bruselas y
presentarse así como un adalid de la paz
global para Rusia En cambio es una
oportunidad de desmentir su soledad esas
diferencias se han quedado subrayadas en
los matices y silencios de los artículos
que han publicado She Putin en la prensa
oficial Putin ha aludido a la
cooperación sin límites esa fórmula
quedó acuñada durante la inauguración de
los Juegos Olímpicos y días después
cuando Rusia invadió Ucrania fue
presentada como una prueba de la
inminente ayuda militar china esa
fórmula también ha sido repetida
insistentemente por Washington para
probar la supuesta falta de neutralidad
china Así que no extraña que sí obviara
esa fórmula y en cambio sí que aludiera
al de no Alianza con Rusia china siempre
ha repetido que no ha salido de Rusia lo
que supondría un deber de ayuda
recíproco sino un simple socio
estratégico también cabe reseñar las
diferentes situaciones desde las que
llegan Sí y Putin el primero acaba de
ser investido presidente por tercera vez
y su posición es sólida tanto en el país
como en el partido al segundo en cambio
una derrota en Ucrania le podría costar
no solo su silla sino algo más si
atendemos a la orden de arresto que ha
dictado la Corte Penal Internacional por
supuesto los crímenes de guerra